When I'm supposed to be dairy-free, can I still eat raw dairy? And the answer is,
no, you can't. So this is a question from somebody who has cancer, right? And if dairy is driving
your cancer, then it doesn't make a difference if it's pasteurized, if it's homogenized, if it's
not pasteurized and homogenized. It doesn't also make a difference whether it's cow dairy or
goat dairy or sheep dairy. So all of those have the capability of driving cancer
and stimulating growth of cancer. So we tested you to be dairy-free, we test all those
dairy. So now this is different. This would be a different question if the person was asking
because they don't have cancer and it's not because the dairy is driving the cancer.
But if they have a dairy allergy, so if the person did, let's say, food sensitivity test,
let's say they did a Cyrix array for testing for cross-reactions to gluten or array 10.
These are testing for KC and the reason why I like the Cyrix is it does differentiate between
different types of dairy. Add it differentiates the form of dairy, meaning it might be cow's milk
is positive, but cheese you can eat. So some people that have a KC sensitivity that's a totally
different ball of wax and they may not react to a certain type of cheese, but they react to
another type of cheese or they react to milk itself. For instance, I know people who could
eat goats, cheese, we're talking about cancer patients who are talking about people with a sensitivity
and can eat goats, cheese, but they can't eat cow's cheese. It's because the KC is slightly changed
and differentiated and the protein itself is different between sources and the protein can be
different and changed and altered when in the cooking process, but that has to do with sensitivity,
that has to do with the presence of antibodies to a protein or a peptide or should have a protein.
So when we talk about cancer and what's driving the cancer, I recommend the dairy free. It doesn't make
any difference in raw dairy, it doesn't make any difference what type of dairy means sheep's dairy,
goat's dairy, cow's dairy. And it's like caveat to those who sometimes ask this question,
are eggs dairy, don't you talk about dairy is coming out of a butter about an animal. So
don't believe it, there's nothing.